the Joe Rogan experience they said that
Dana I gotta talk to Dana this weekend
he probably if he tells me I can't tell
you well you tell me I can't tell
everybody else I'll get there's some
sort of a fight for a doll
I think it's Connor on fight Island
that's what my fight brains going
towards because he said we have a bigger
fight from Ozma doll because they said
kemal vs. monster doll for the belt
right that's the talk Fred goes we have
a more exciting fight my client well
there's only two guys who'd be bigger
Connor
now I would love if just B's but I don't
think so SP you know why no belt no belt
enough to worry about GSP taking off I'm
taking off GSP fights MOSFET all that be
dragged and the nice guy versus the bad
boy jag and I Connor Mazda dolls the
fight but then I was even thing of GSP
doesn't really seem Connor amazing fight
at 170 amazing well I don't like Connor
at 70 but GSP Connor at once
dude ready for this how about Maz at all
Nick Diaz Oh Nick Diaz GSP Connor same
card fight Island good lord
I might have to take a trip to wherever
the [ __ ] it is I might fly down there
what do you think fine is I don't know
it's one of that uh Bronson's Islands
the Virgin Island guy the Virgin Records
really [ __ ] yeah I'm pretty sure it's
one of his Islands where'd you hear that
the water cooler that's a that's a it
might be but dude Nick Nick Diaz Maz at
all now does Nick Diaz definitely want
to fight I don't know but I was in my
brain I'm thinking who's out there who
could be bigger than komaru spin Maz at
all see the Connor or Nick
well Nick would work because Maz would
all beat up his brother exactly in
Redemption he asked for that fight but
it's always tough with the negotiations
of the Diaz's well especially Nick
because Nick hasn't fought since
Anderson solo go to I'm pointing Maz
with all common when when Maas walls on
food truck Diaries hit off-camera him
and his manager was like dune
it's Connor Maas at all that's our fight
they told us they wanted to that's the
fight that was months ago that was right
that was after he beat could he beat
last mile yeah be Diaz right that's
right
that was low that's right yeah I have
him on literally like a week after that
and he was like oh Connors the fight
they're telling us he wants fight we
want the fight wow that's a big fight
Hospital Conor Jesus good talking we'll
be off the charts to a press tour for
that man yeah you can't scare mods but
all either your Ma's Vidal's a big fella
I know he fought 55 before I mean he
fought 55 for a long time but it wasn't
his weight class I don't see Comic Con
I'm at 70 though he's gonna fight him in
79 I was not gonna go to 55 really is
that what they said that's that's what
they said that's that's what they're
talking about
well don't Floyd Canelo on as much as I
love Maas with all the O'Connor still
the top top dog in town so you got to
meet him a little bit halfway so he's
the top dog in town but I'm telling you
man when you go to the UFC and you see
the pop that Maas whoa dog gets there's
this change in the reception show he's a
star he's a huge star right now I mean
he might not be as big a star over the
world as Connor is he's not he's
definitely not Connors Connors eclipsed
the sport but Marvin I was one of the
biggest stars himself he's giant easily
I think that fight would be bonkers just
straight-up bonkers Connor said he wants
to fight three times this year but
that's not happening so they're gonna
give him some big fights damn man
Mazz Vidal Connor
[Applause]